so again my name is tomomi
and i think people who know me
know me as i'm the girly mac it's my
twitter handle
and i'm a mobile focused friend and
engineer with the ui focus
and currently i'm working in nokia i've
been working for nokia for like a
year or so as a
web standard you know open web advocate
and before working on nokia i've been
working
for palm web os if you remember
and yeah i've been taking oh gosh
it was loud all of a sudden yeah i've
been taking charge of the ui
of paul webos platform for
a little in upon free phones and
touchpad
and previously i've been working yahoo
mobile so
basically i've been working for the
mobile space for a long time
and also yeah besides mobile i'm also
known as
http status cat lady the reason is
you might not know me but i think you
might have
seen those stuff i have created
that gave me some accidental 15 minutes
of fame and
it was totally unintentional but it went
by at all it's kind of
cool so yeah
i can talk about cats for the entire
time but i'm not going to
so now i'm going to talk about
javascript since i'm in jscope
in html5 for mobile
yeah so okay i'm going to start
talking about a url scheme so this is
not in javascript actually and
this is some old-school stuff it's
nothing new
and defined by oma for xhtml mp
that's xhtml mobile profile so it's been
there and implemented browser for a long
time
and you probably already know just like
a male 2
but it's sort of obscure spanx you might
not know so you can just initiate a
phone call
by giving this a url scheme well tl tell
to make a phone call and it you know it
basically opens up a phone app if
your device has phone or you can even
text by using
sms this game
and there's something i recently heard
about like what wg have white listed
some
other uri scheme like bitcoin lately i
i haven't seen how it works and stuff
but it'll be kind of cool
and also something like fb like custom
known standard uri scheme to open up
facebook app if it's on ios
and stuff but that's again it's
non-standard
so the ui actually ux um it's really
depends on os
and you know which operating system the
browser is on
so first screenshot here is actually
from
windows form format so once you your
user tab the link
of the phone phone numbers on it
actually goes to this screen so
the user has a chance to edit before
making a phone call
might have to add like you know can't
record and stuff
in the next one it's on android i don't
remember if this screenshot is from
chrome or firefox or other browsers
basically because it you know goes to
the same screen
basically let's open up the phone app
and in either way you know the browser
never make
phone call in initial phone call by
itself without the user's knowledge
user always have to initiate a call so
in this case
you know of course you know nothing
happens until you use a tap just
call button so it's safe and another one
is for sms
on android it's basically open up the
messaging app
and again it doesn't send a message by
itself
and geolocation is another thing i don't
really have to explain too much i'm
pretty sure everybody here are already
known but this is you know another way
that you can access hardware
and there are more than a few ways to
because you know your device
doesn't necessarily have to have gps so
you know it's easier in detecting the
user's current location
location by gps satellite actual gps
or cell id and assisted gps
is a software-based or wi-fi based
stations
and then this basically this is a car
snippet of you know how you get the
current positions once you get the
location coordinates get successful back
here
and again this has access permission for
users as well
so i mean the developer can
steal information about where you are at
so it always you know ask
the browser make it into ask users to
give information
and this ui really depends on browser
so you probably haven't seen those
before because these screenshots are
taken from the first one is from loeb os
and another one's amigo so you probably
haven't seen it
and then the next one is actually not
from geolocation this is for okay user
media permissions
again you use user media
never takes your photos so you know open
up the webcam
without your permission so this is safe
for users
and another cool features another you
know thing you can just do is javascript
is device orientation events
so there is a three dom events to get
the information
about the physical orientation movement
of the
device and the information the basic
information you can get into a gyro
accelerometer and compass
and this is um actually this diagram
comes from a developer website i took it
from there and it should read it's
pretty good
informative webpage and this explains
how the device orientation event works
so it has
basically the motion of the device in
you know which way
rotates so alpha beta and gamma and
alpha is a one it actually works as
compass
so it detects in north south and west
east
and it is oh yeah and the device motion
is like
accelerometer i mean so it
basically tells how fast you know your
device
travels maybe i would say so let's say
if you're driving
with your phone or more like you have a
phone car
and how you know you can tell i mean
by using this vend you can pretty much
tell how fast your device is traveling
with you in a car
and compass needs calibration it's
that's
exactly what i said the compass needs
calculation it gives the
supposed to give a ui about you know the
a figure
or maybe infinity or whatever but i
don't think it's working i mean it's
been implemented in any
browsers yet i haven't seen it's working
so this is a quick demo i wrote
it's really not hold on
so i use a the device orientation event
so basically used with css3
you know transform to just move this a
triangle
with the movement of this device and
when you put the device in
flat surface it gives the answer
but then recently my friend told me
about
this github for full page oh
i don't know i just tested it it's not
working so this page is kind of cute
you know it has a parallax effect and it
has when you move the mouse it moves in
the background moves
and apparently i use the device
orientation events too so when you hit
this [ __ ] extend to here for a full on
your
tablet or something you know it moves
around as
you move it's kind of silly but it's
cute
oh now i don't know how to get back
so this is actual code called snippet
from the demo i just wrote
so basically just using you know
listening event
and the device on device orientation
events there
and i get the info from the alpha beta
gamma
and using the css and then
sorry keep stepping on something
the browser support is okay you know
it's been
supported in most of mobile browsers
here and when
i actually had to tell you about when
i'm talking about this browser
compatibility here
i'm talking about mobile so you might
say it's like oh it's been supported by
from such such even in earlier and such
but i'm just talking about mobile here
so
when i'm talking about chrome today here
i'm talking about chrome for android
so the earliest version of the chrome
number for android is 18
so basically when i say 18 means it's
been working
since the first version and same thing
for firefox
so i'm not talking about firefox for
desktop talking about firefox for
android and unfortunately i don't have
firefox os
device yet so i haven't tested any so
when i
talk about firefox it's only for android
and the opera it's not it's not the
webkit
based offer it's presto based upper and
so it's over 12.
and yeah it's a blackberry tan and the
last icon has a tizen
so i actually just got poison device
last week
so i had tested a little bit this
weekend so i don't know much about this
device i mean the browser yet but
anyway i test it and it's working fine
and it
the latest tizen browser a bit by the
way tizen it's a lip kit
it's a webkit to base browser
and the use cases of use cases for those
apis i just mentioned about it's a
this ios app called pizzacompat
actually i i don't really use ios so
i haven't really used this apple myself
but i read about it
so basically what it does is well user
had a compass so this pizza compass
tells you where you are and
the um location
and it just gives you you know the
nearest pizza place and like
yeah you know what i think you can do
that with javascript pretty easily right
so basically what you have to do is you
know use the navigator geolocation to
get the user location
and use a um user confess you know
device orientation events with the alpha
get information about alpha and get
convex
and just you know use some apis maps and
local business apis from somewhere and
just get the you know
the grabbed phone phone numbers or make
a phone call by using this uh
tele url scheme so you should be able to
do
it
a camera access so yeah now you can
you know access the device native camera
by using javascript
and one of those is a webrtc it's a part
of the webrtc
frequently and using it using media
and the mobile browser support will get
user media it's not
quite yet so looks like opera is really
the pioneer like a first one to support
it
but again that's not a webkit webkit
opera i
tested it with a latest opera you know
webkit-based
not blink yet for for mobile i think
it's a 14 it's a webkit based
and wasn't working sadly and
chrome 26 i put star there because
you still need a this you know webkit
extension i mean
the bender prefix but yeah this
is a i think the newest chrome now it's
27 but it just happened recently it
wasn't working before
it just started supporting i think and
the other
the browsers like firefox and python
it looks like it's being implemented
because you know
the feature detections but you know
feature detections lie
so it doesn't mean it works so i
didn't make it work maybe i did wrong i
don't know
so that was the actual photo i took from
my android phone
of this little silly demo
not that one i made it for some
responsible
demo so again yeah it has a user
permission so
we never use a you know webcam wizard
deformation oh it's not really working
yeah basically it has a javascript
facial detection to make my
perfect spongebob
it's a little slow it's not really
falling or maybe because i'm not looking
at the camera
yeah it works on the phone too now you
know
android oh still
alright
oh my gosh it's funny
okay
yeah again so that's actually tested on
a nexus 4
but another things another there's
another way to
you know um access
the native camera and this is something
actually my favorite the html media
capture
this is different from us and get user
media it's not using
i mean you see there's no javascript
involved there right it's just a
mockup so you see this is nothing more
than an input here right input element
it's the file type
type it's file so this is just like a
file upload
but the difference is so now we have a
the two
attributes here the accept and capture
so basically specified accept images
and a caption camera and this is
this is all the implementation allows
the old specifications
but this is what currently browser
support and the new spec is captured as
a boolean
because um when you specified image it's
obviously you try to get the camera
there's other things like um the record
camera recorder
um microphones in the video
as well so you don't have to specify its
camera it is
but anyways this is new and i don't
think any browsers have supported yet
so currently um chrome android
blackberry 10 and tizen support is just
fine
and i have tested ios firefox on android
and ie as well but the the reason i put
stars as the partial support is
um well you can still access cameras
but um the browser hasn't implemented
this correctly
that means that the capture attributes
not working so
basically when you try to access or
try to use this the browser asks if you
want to
take a camera or choose pictures from
your hard drive somewhere like album
something
that's fine but it's still wrong so bugs
being filed
i.e 10.
that's another thing a future detection
lies so it
appears to be supported but it doesn't
work
so i asked the ie guys on microsoft and
apparently this is disabled for
mobile when i'm using windows a in
windows rt
at least it supports partially but it
just doesn't do anything
for mobile phones and it's pretty bad
experience
and this is a demo of actual app i wrote
this app is a web app and it's called
chrome off camera
and this is entirely written in
javascript
so basically what it does oh
basically what it does is uh the tap the
button and take the photo
and apply the filter and save it in this
saving locally in the browser or
send it to the server and you may have
seen
app like this before somewhere i'm not
trying to select somebody for 1 billion
but
it's open source i did it for free
so yeah you might have seen similar
interface somewhere
so again i wrote entirely in javascript
and use the html media capture well i
explained quickly
i actually have done like the entire
presentation about this app it has so
much to talk about actually
so again yeah i did a html5 use case
talk before on a different conferences
because i want to show you know what
actually how you can use html5
features to write apps so for that
particular app what i did is taking a
photo
with a native camera by using html media
capture
and this camera returns a picture as a
file object
and as you can get from file reader and
then
dump the whole you know pictures into a
canvas
using the draw image method to draw the
image object in canvas
then it's going to get image data to
get the whole the pixel data from the
you know
contain a copy of the pixel data from
the context
then and just manipulate those pixels
you know to
give give like grayscale filters or
you know the sapient kind of stuff then
and use we are using a canvas to block
method to store the blog and to
yeah store locally with using index tv
then finally you can let you use it
upload a photo by using xhrm course
actually indexeddb it's a tricky one it
starts because i say blob
stored blobling xdb but only firefox
supports uh
storage blob and index db that's a whole
other big topic so i'm not going to have
time to talk about but anyways
for chrome in other browsers what i did
was just store in
basics 12 string so it's huge string so
it's really not a good idea to
do so i think anyways so it's on
github it's open sourced it's not done
yet but
well it's working and
okay so move on to a battery status api
so another things you can do with
javascript it's detecting how much juice
left in your phone or
you know even you can detect if his
phone's being charged or not
but you using those events and charging
change
level change events and
you well the browser support is still
not great it's only supported by firefox
and tyson so far
and for tizen you need a get a prefix
and for firefox i think you can
probably save to drop now yeah i think
the firefox guys dropped
the prefix after version 16
and this is the actual code i wrote i
mean
just damn quick demo and actual photos
so
you can see this is charged so it knows
it's been charged another one's
not charged but note that the pilot has
a 67
left
and the vibration api is another things
you can do is so yeah there's something
called the vibrate
at the navigator object navigate the
vibration is you
still need a prefix as well
well basically what it does is vibrate
your phone
i oh you know what i don't think you can
hear well i have a
it's buzzing now think
yeah i expect it have actual mic so you
can hear but anyways
i don't have a good use case for this so
just
demo and another cool stuff
is you can access the light sensor on
the device
and i just use yeah that's easy the
device light
event so um
the value gives actual
brightness of the environment around the
phone
in unit of lux so basically gives
numbers like a 400 oh this is actually
observation from my
galaxy nexus phone
so i'm not sure about accuracy of this
but
yeah but basically when you i'm in an
indoor outdoor
well then daylight it gives them you
know different values
and i live in san francisco and it's
foggy so i couldn't really get tested
for
over a thousand actually and i should
test it here on
another time and sunny florida but
unfortunately my galaxy nexus phones get
stolen
a while ago so now i have a nexus 4 but
i think
light sensor of this bone somehow not
right it means
i don't get it's supposed to given the
value in double
but i always get integer value and it's
really low so i'm not sure if it's
the light sensor is working another
thing says so i just said the value is
in double but
then as a new specification it's like
yeah that's really
confusing why don't you give just a you
know string value
it's easier to understand and dim normal
bright maybe a good idea
but it's too new and no browsers have
supported yet
i had to go quick
it's yeah it's a demo but just some you
know
try to create a shadow on the phone just
just to see the number changes
i know i should write a better demo but
yeah
approximately events something similar
so
you can access approximately sensor of
the device
so you can tell if the object is nearby
or far maybe
ears touching the phone or not but it's
still
this is too new i guess none of the
browsers support it but i'm hoping
it's going to be supportive soon and
there are more apis
i really don't have time to even explain
but
there's a bunch of other more apis maybe
some browsers already have supported
maybe not
well one particularly interesting for me
as a clipboard api has cut and copy and
paste that would be cool
and network discovery is like um
universal plug-and-play multi-media
devices like you can
you know operate the other devices and
as well
and full screen maybe it's supported
already
and gamepad api and push notifications
and there's certain apis or not
i'm not sure but like contact apis and
calendar apis are
actually they're specified based on the
web intents
but apparently google ditched web intent
so i don't know what happens to those
apis so i had to just keep on
because now you see mozilla's doing
something new called web activities
i'm not sure if that's going to replace
the web intent
so something i don't know
so that's about it and um thank you very
much
and my website girlmac.com and my
twitter is girly mac
and the school mac it's kind of
confusing has underscore or not and
and my github doesn't have underscore
serene i have to talk really quick and
i oh gosh i really already run out of
time but
thank you and if you have questions just
just talk to me
you